you
hi everyone and welcome to the press
conference just at the beginning here of
the showdown in st. Louis a rapid in
blitz exhibition match between former
world champion and grandmaster Gary
Kasparov and grandmaster Nigel short a
big round of applause for our players so
before we begin our press conference and
our exciting news that we have today we
have some formalities to perform which
is the drawing of the lots so the format
of the match between Gary and Nigel will
be too rapid games and for blitz games
over the next two days all of the action
would be covered live on us chess champs
calm but it's important for the players
to know which order they will play with
what color who will start with white and
who will finish with white so in these
two boxes here I have some very nice
pins from Saks Fifth Avenue one of them
is black and the other one is gold
the player who chooses the black pen
will be they don't make white pens so
much so the player who chooses the black
pen will have the black pieces in the
first game the player who chooses the
gold pen will help the white pieces in
the first game and grandmaster Kasparov
if you would do us the honors of picking
your poison not that one ah Garry chose
the gold pen so he'll have white in Game
one Nigel just to make sure I'm honest
yeah and a black pen all right standing
to my right is a man who probably needs
no introduction within the chess circles
Michal Kwiatkowski
is the driving force behind the Kasparov
chess foundation here in the United
States through a cooperative effort
between the Kasparov chess foundation in
the Chess Club and scholastic Center of
st. Louis the young stars the young
rising chess players in the country
train regularly with Garry and other
grandmasters Michael all of his hard
work certainly has paid off we've seen a
lot of our young juniors like Sam seve
and progressed through the ranks and
become very talented chess players and
Michael will do us the honors of hosting
this press conference and kicking things
off Michael thank you
ladies and gentlemen I'm honored to be
moderator of this special press
conference the announcement of
groundshare store and before we'll take
questions from here and from our
worldwide audience online I would like
to introduce those who participated
these press conference
first of all react sintel
founder of chess club and scholastic
center of san luis
garry kasparov former world champion
greatest ambassador to promote the sport
of chess and this grand tour next to him
Nigel short his longtime friend and
opponent and Challenger for World
Championship urine all in the ansan or
we call him JJ president of Norwich has
Federation our guests from Oslo and
least but not last our dearest friend
Malcolm Payne who is representing a
London chest classic and chess promotion
limited from London I also like to take
opportunity to introduce Maurice Ashley
grandmaster from the United States who
will be helping us to take lessons from
worldwide audience and right now I would
like to pass the board to executive
director of Chess Club and scholastic
Center of San Luis Tony reach you don't
know how hard it is going to keep my
mouth shut about what I'm about to say
and I'm very excited to tell you that
the Chess Club and scholastic Center st.
Louis in partnership with Norway chess
and the London chess classic are
announcing the 2015 grand chest tour so
the grand chest tour is a circuit of
tournaments three
that will be played throughout the year
each of the tournaments will have the
same prize funding structure nine of the
10 players will be the same across all
the events and in total the players will
be competing for more than a million
dollars in prize money $300,000 from
each event plus another hundred and
fifty thousand dollar prize fund for the
tour overall so the grand treasurer
really represents the pinnacle of chess
around the world it's the gold standard
these three events have established
themselves as as the premier the
flagship events down to every detail for
an organization and execution to
spectator experience and conditions for
the players we share a passion and a
commitment to make sure that
professional chess is brought to
everyone worldwide to the highest
caliber that we can and we're very lucky
to have been inspired in this project by
Garry Kasparov he's connected our three
events and the organizers from each of
them and and now we have the grand chest
tour thank you Tony and right now let's
go back to questions from audience here
and the world wide if anyone you have
questions here in the audience please
address we do have some questions
already online we have Richard Palliser
who's the editor of chess magazine and
he asked do you envision the tour being
expanded to include more tournaments I
will pass this to organizer from London
Malcolm Payne come up to the high
standards that we intend to set we'd be
delighted to have on board we are in
discussions
fourth tournament already but they won't
be in the tour this year and we'd be
particularly welcoming and tournaments
from other continents your next question
also from Ridgid palace sir is do you
envision the tour excuse me can you see
a way that a female player like how a
faun will be taking part in the future
edition of the tournament will come up
and reach the world's top ten top dozen
and then we'll be delighted to have a
female player in the tour because I can
continue there are also some more online
questions why were these three
tournaments in particular Norway chess
Inc fill Cup and London chest classic
chosen for the tour these in particular
I think Sonya would be so the the sink
tail Cup the London chess classic in
Norway chess as I mentioned these these
are tournaments that have been around
for a few years now and have certainly
established both to the players and to
the audience to the spectators what a
chess event should be it's not just
about having chess boards and sets it's
not just about providing a well-lit room
that's quiet all of those things are
very important but more than that the
players are really the superstars of
chess you know we are we are so lucky to
be able to spotlight and showcase their
talent and to bring it to the audience
in a way that is understandable
digestible and entertaining at the same
time live commentary online live
commentary at each of the locations as I
mentioned every Detailers is considered
and these three events really represent
the very best chess around the world
thank you Tony
hello first of all thank you for hosting
anything that makes chest such a
wonderful sport to watch and to follow
and well I just wondering how does it
work exactly what's the format how are
the points awarded how do we determine
who the winner is
thank you grandmaster and nearest
questions and i'll as to malcolm pain
again sure so we started by looking at
the feed a rating list way back in
January whenever the we started
determining who the players would be and
we invited the top 10 players by rating
off of that list as some players had
other commitments or obligations and
we're not able to participate in the
tour we went further down and invited
other players who in some way enhanced
the event they bring something
interesting to the table through their
sportsmanship and professionalism and
their fighting spirit so the nine of the
ten players as I mentioned will be the
same across all three events the 10th
place is a organizers wild card it may
or may not be the same person from event
to event but the wild card is eligible
for tour points and so after an event
has ended based upon the final standings
players will earn extra points
we call them tour points and at the end
of the cycle after the third event is
completed the top three players by tour
points will receive an extra prize money
so each of the organizers have
contributed an extra $50,000 to that
prize fund and we will award out first
second and third
seventy-five thousand fifty thousand and
twenty five thousand dollars and the
structure there there could be ties
there could be playoffs and all of that
all of the details for that will be
posted online at Grand chest or calm
another question we have is what's the
difference between this tour and the
feed a Grand Prix it's better
that's I think it's quite obvious that
it's the first event since Gmail World
Cup tour in 1988-89 whenever all I have
to emphasize all leading players
including the world champion who
participate in the circuit and I think
it's it's it's the only way to promote
the game through this big tournaments
when people know that everybody
including the world champion so will
will take will participate in the
Indians and again hopefully that this
tool will grow and will give more
flexibility for the players the problem
is that really we just mentioned now
they are due to the fact that it's only
three tournaments and everybody must
play in all three which cost understand
certain problems with schedule but if we
see the the the growth of the top of the
circuit to four or five tournaments it
will it will offer players flexibility
and they will play you know they'll be
able to you miss one or two events still
to count is still having enough points
for the overall overall count so I'm
extremely excited because we know from
other professional sports that circuits
are the best way to bring attention of
the public that is not following all
chess events continuing along that what
was the initial feedback from the
players what has been the initial
feedback from the top players especially
we're part of this tour I probably will
campaign extremely keen to players
replied extremely quickly what I would
say is with reference to the to the
previous question about what's
difference between this and the feed a
Grand Prix well in in this circuit the
players are being rewarded with prize
money that befits their status as Top
Sportsman which is not the case in the
few days
continuing with the online questions
what is Garry Kasparov's role in the
tour so this question organizer from
Norwich s president Norwich Chess
Federation Gary's Kasparov's role is
that he is let's say the man who took
the initiative and has been advising all
three of us how to put this together so
he's an inspiration and I received in
question of whether you're going to
expand events beyond 2015 whether it
would be three or more events maybe to
expand it it will be expanding in 60 and
if I may just add the real vision for
this is to make it truly global so we
love the fact that we have some
fantastic events in Europe in the United
States and we are hoping to expand in
particular to Asia and Africa heck if
you can put a chess team together in
Antarctica I bet we could have an event
there as well given that there are only
so many tournaments that you can have
during the year how will this conflict
with the current chess schedule because
there a lot of chess tournaments that
fides running as well we've worked hard
to make sure that we don't overlap with
other events sometimes that's
unavoidable but we've certainly been in
contact and communication with other
organizers from around the world
obviously a top player schedule is very
tight I know guys like the silly Evandro
has played 200 games join a trading
games a year or something like that
doesn't leave a lot of downtime in
between so we understand that there will
be some scheduling conflicts and as Gary
commented it'll be nice to be able to
expand the tour to the point where we
have some flexibility with scheduling
and players being able to choose some
subset of the events in which to
participate
which is that you know right now fides
events you know clash with clash with
stuff so we got the world team
championship take place the same time as
sham Kia I mean what the Grantchester
will be doing is laying out its schedule
a long time in advance so for 2016
you're going to hear about that schedule
straight up at the end of the London
shows classic event climax of the 2015
tour we'll be putting those laying those
dates down through and then you know
we'll avoid crashes in the best way you
can I believe someone mentioned the
challenge are picking a wild-card
what will the white card be just among
the top players as you go down the list
or will you pick players who may be from
the country itself Tony sure so the the
wild card really is an opportunity for
the organizer to spotlight their event
or enhance it in some way so I would
imagine that the organizers will select
wild cards who are at or near their peak
strength obviously some of the best
chess players in the world they'll look
for players who have that fighting
spirit who have a sense of camaraderie
within the chess community who have that
ability to be a true chess professional
and people who would like to spotlight
as the top players you know our ultimate
goal from this is to create superstars
out of these players we'd like to see
them mention in the same sentences as
Barry Bonds or John McEnroe or any of
the other great Pele you know so in
doing these types of events the
organizers really have that opportunity
and that flexibility to bring in a chess
player who adds something unique to
their event maybe JJ will follow up on
that because Norway chess has a
different approach we organized a
qualification tournaments with six
players most of them from Scandinavia
which is fairly close by and the winner
will have their
place in OHS we have done this before
with the mass of two players last year
seems I understand and young music
humming and we see this as an
opportunity to let's say increase the
activity among the best players in
Scandinavia gets a big question here
that is sort of being touched on what is
the real vision for these tournaments
what why this chest or what is this
going to do for chess overall for Garry
Kasparov food so better than anybody
else as I mentioned already so there
were attempts in the past to create this
this kind of network of tournaments
those guys and I played in this in 88 89
tournament then a new one started but
it's it failed to to pick up the steam
and with with such a fierce competition
between different professional sports
you need something that could be put in
the calendar and we know now that was
with Magnus Carlsen as a young world
champion young star that attracts
television not only his country but
worldwide so there's an opportunity to
bring an attention public attention to
to DC to tournaments to put this great
players in the spotlight and having the
circuit is the best way to make people
on television in in in in print media to
follow this lead this events if the
organizers succeed in attracting events
from other continents Asia was mentioned
Africa was mentioned and it did the tool
becomes truly global I could see you
know that's a huge opportunity sky's the
limit because we may have something that
will be on the calendar of the
professional sports events and
eventually will you know make chest an
attractive show they'll be overstated
actually the whole point of the circular
or one of the biggest benefits of the
circuit is the the attention it will
draw to the game of chess much like in
golf
or tennis or or many other sports that
have this structure where it's a
year-long competition and at the end the
players who do really well across those
event or generally recognized as the
best in their sport I think that that
will really give chess and innovative
opportunity to reach new markets
including television and hopefully be
broadcast around the world have any of
the top players been confirmed as yet
that they will be playing in these three
competitions or how many of them have
done so already so far as far as I know
confirmed eight players and Cromley
decline within a few days the ninth
player will be announced so the eight
players that we have confirmed thus far
are current world champion Magnus
Carlsen Fabiano car you wanna Hikaru
Nakamura Vishy Anand
Alex Chris shook I need Gary I don't
think series in there I'm sorry let me
try again
Magnus Carlsen Fabiano car you wanna
Hikaru Nakamura Vishy Anand Veselin
Topalov Alex Grisham Anisha kiri and
Levon Aronian
are eight players that we've confirmed
thus far the average rating by the way
based upon the April rating list is 2801
amongst those eight players eight
players average rating 2801 and what
about sponsors do our sponsors from each
individual location or are you looking
for sponsors of the entire tour in
general a main sponsor also for the tour
but so far we only have sponsorships for
each event but in the future we will
definitely let say the more TV coverage
we will get the bigger value we can
deliver back to the main sponsor of the
full tour it is the goal to raise the
price one beyond a million dollars I
mean a million is that's a good start
but but much bigger than that it will go
up gradually for sure
the more price tournaments more than
three then the price overall price one
goes up but as JJ pointed out it's very
important to to attract public attention
the moments the this this the idea that
this circuit you know brings enough
publicity I think the the title sponsors
will will pay close attention to what
we're doing and eventually will probably
pay a good dollar top dollar to the
event in particularly the Tor prize fund
I see expanding pretty quickly since
each of the organizers contribute
$50,000 to the overall tor price when if
we had just two more events we've almost
doubled the overall tor prize fund if we
made direct this question at Rex
Sinquefield well what is your feeling
about being a part of this tour or
bringing bringing this one leg to the
United States I think it's terrific for
st. Louis and I think it's fair to say
that we were sort of one of the pioneers
of doing this in this case pioneer was a
good thing usually you know pioneers are
those who get the arrows but now we're
really honored to be to be part of this
and we're especially honored that people
felt they had to meet the standards of
the Sinquefield cup and the debt would
set the standard for the entire tour and
we're all in agreement on that that's
kind of guarantee that the tour is going
to be an extremely high-quality event
especially with new venues coming in
these three organizations already proved
as a golden standard of the quality of
professional chess there for affiliation
of these three organizations guarantees
highest quality of professional chairs
and the sport of chairs to promote our
sport even further nigel as a
professional player yourself are you
hoping to play in the tour two week I'm
afraid yes sir that's
but I'm working on it
my ratings going off at the moment so
what's your opinion of such a tour being
brought together I think it's wonderful
I think it's great to see these players
all together and it brings some cohesion
to the chess world already been played
I've already played my first veterans
tournament so to have the support of
guys like Nigel and Gary you know
professional chess players world
champions and world champion contenders
players who have really seen the
pinnacle of chess around the world to
have their endorsement and their support
and their vision and inspiration through
this whole process certainly is
inspiring as an organizer and I think
ultimately will lead to improvements
across the three events and an hopefully
more events in the future and I believe
that it couldn't be better
time for this announcement if we want an
EF match against two legends Gary
Kasparov a Nigel short over this weekend
and I would like to thank proteins here
and audience worldwide who followed this
press conference and please turn to www
and chest or dot-com for further news
and information it would be updated as
it as soon as possible
also make sure you tweet at us at
Grantchester
thank you very much